[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i'm going to
explain a chinese fantasy romance film
called oversize love
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
xiaoshi is a young photographer who owns
an at-home studio somewhere in east
china she is always around beautiful
women for shoots which makes her
extremely insecure about her overweight
body although xiaoshi has tried many
methods to lose weight she never seems
to be successful as a hobby she loves
chasing after celebrities her current
obsession is an actor and model named
huang ki while reading one of his
interviews she comes across a comment
claiming that he only likes girls who
are 45 kilograms or below right after
xiaoshi gets on the scale and sees that
she is almost double that weight her
friend asks her to not feel bad about
her body because she has managed to land
a handsome friend like han han has been
shaoshi's companion since middle school
he is currently a famous music producer
and is still best friends with her when
shaushi's friend suggests she date him
she claims that they're just friends
deep down she believes that han would
never be with someone like her han and
xiao xi have a tradition of meeting at
the park every saturday to exercise when
her friend reminds her of the date
shaoxi rushes to the park a flashback
shows us the day han and shao xi met for
the first time in contrast to now han
used to be the overweight one in middle
school he was bullied regularly by his
classmates but couldn't speak up for
himself he also didn't have many friends
so when shaoxi saved him from the
bullies one day he instantly became
attached to her she was the first person
to recognize his musical talent and the
one who made him pursue his dreams back
in the present they meet at the park to
exercise half an hour into the workout
xiaoshi falls to the ground as per the
tradition they go to their favorite
street side restaurant and eat a lot of
food the bystanders are shocked to see
the amount of food shaoxing can eat
alone but it doesn't bother han in the
least he has never had a problem with
her weight and always tells her she is
beautiful one day the friends go
shopping for clothes buying clothes has
always been difficult for shashi as an
overweight woman she tries on a white
dress that tears down the neckline
because of her size she embarrassingly
has to buy it because of the damage on
their way back home han asks her what
she wants for her birthday but xiao she
jokes that she wants a handsome man to
date her after the two separate shaushi
finds an abandoned rabbit on the road
she feels bad for it and brings it home
but fails to notice that its eyes are
glowing the following morning a crew of
people knock at her door wanting to
shoot in the studio because of a last
minute change she allows them after
finding out that the model of the shoot
is her celebrity crush huang ki the
entire shoot feels like a dream to her
later huang ki tells her that she has
pretty eyes and could be a model if she
loses weight but then she overhears his
assistant calling her ugly asking him to
stay away from people like her for the
sake of his image starting the next day
she wraps her legs with plastic eats
healthily takes supplements and
exercises harder than ever but after two
weeks of hard work she barely loses one
kilogram that night she accidentally
breaks the sofa with her weight and
falls flat on the floor as she lies
there hopelessly she notices the rabbit
moving around almost as though it is
leading her somewhere she follows the
animal and reaches an abandoned mansion
in the neighborhood when she enters the
house the floor swallows her into a
colorful upside down room shaoxi panics
and tries to move but gravity doesn't
seem to work in this room then an old
man appears in front of her asking her
to make a wish initially shaoshi freaks
out and tries to run away but the lack
of gravity only makes her float when she
calms down the man gives her a blue
potion called the dream fixer it is
supposed to make her dream come true in
an instant although skeptical at first
shaoshi takes a gulp of it and goes to
bed when she wakes up the next morning
she can almost not recognize herself in
the mirror her body has shrunk
significantly making her slim for a few
minutes she lays on the bed trying to
take everything in then she gets a call
from her friend asking her to bring the
pictures from the last photo shoot to
funky's assistant when none of her
clothes fit shaoxi wears the one that
she had to buy because of the damage on
her way to huanke's hotel the people she
knew before do not recognize her while
the bypassers turn around to admire her
beauty similarly hunky is also smitten
by her he comments that he has seen her
before but doesn't know where
suddenly shashi's chest starts getting
bigger followed by her back realizing
that she is turning back into her older
self she runs away without an
explanation at night she again takes the
potion and by the morning she gets
skinny for the second time han arrives
at the house worried because she hasn't
picked up her phone for an entire day he
barges in to see her wearing a headscarf
initially she pretends to be shaoxi's
friend to avoid having to explain the
situation but han recognizes her
instantly he had never seen her as less
beautiful because of her weight so even
though she is significantly thinner he
doesn't notice much difference shaoxie
tells him about the potion and what it
does to the human body han doesn't want
to believe it but the result is right in
front of him minutes later she yet again
turns fat and finds out that the effect
of the potion only lasts for 10 hours
han doesn't like that she's changing her
body unnaturally he also feels jealous
of the actor huang ki knowing that she
took the potion to impress him han's
assistant who is in the fashion industry
takes it upon himself to give shaushi a
makeover after a week of trying out
different hairstyles and facials xiaoshi
turns into a beautiful young woman a
complete contrast from how she was prior
meanwhile han hires swanky to model for
his next music video on the set huanki
claims that he doesn't feel the
chemistry with the female lead and wants
someone who is prettier offended the
female lead quits and storms off the set
just then xiaoshi arrives looking more
stunning than ever hwang ki suggests
they use her as the model since she has
the body and the face for it initially
han doesn't approve of this but when the
director supports the idea he has no
choice but to agree for the next week
the team meets every day for the shoot
shaushi fangirls over huang ki making
han jealous he takes his frustration out
by pointing out little flaws in huanki's
acting and making him take several shots
an unsaid rivalry is established between
the guys one day the director adds a
kissing scene to the script han is
absolutely against the idea so instead
he makes them cover their faces with an
umbrella to make it look like they are
kissing the following day huanki invites
shaoxi out on a date they go to the
movies but notice that han is right
behind their seat when asked what he is
doing there he claims that it is only a
coincidence everywhere the couple goes
he follows them acting like he is going
the same way even when they book a
private cabin at a restaurant he stands
by the door to keep an eye on them when
it starts to get dark xiaoshi wants to
return home but huanki insists she come
to a party with his friends a few
minutes into meeting his friend group
her fingers begin to swell followed by
her entire arm she rushes to the
bathroom and hides inside a stall crying
hysterically outside huanki and his
friends are waiting for her leaving her
no way to escape just when the truth is
about to be outed han comes to save her
in a mascot costume he makes her wear it
and brings her out without hwanky
noticing when he sees han talking to
another overweight woman and claims that
he can do much better than some random
fat girl shaoshi hears the comment and
is left disheartened she knows that
wanky only likes her because of her
beauty but cannot seem to let the idea
go of them being together han drops her
off at home and tells her that she is
not the person she used to be he also
assures her that she will get plenty of
guys even if she remains the way she is
show she knows he is lying because even
he could never see her as more than a
friend a flashback reveals that in high
school xiaoshi was in love with han but
one day she overheard han's friend
making fun of her and han saying that he
doesn't like her in that way she stopped
trying to pursue him after that later
han and his friend are drinking when the
guy asks him if he regrets not asking
shout she out when she was still fat han
remembers the time in high school that
he heard shashi tell her friends that
she had no feelings for him because of
the miscommunication they never
expressed their feelings to each other
even though they were in love the
following evening their filming crew
meets at a restaurant to celebrate the
last day of the shoot han and twang ki
meet in the bathroom and get into a
slight altercation the conflict quickly
turns into a physical fight the others
from the crew have to drag them away
from each other to stop them later han
and xiao xi walk back home together he
asks her to think about how huanki will
react if she goes back to being fat in
turn xiao xi claims that han hasn't
treated her any better when she mentions
the time he was bullied han's eyes glow
as the rabbits did earlier xiaoshi
doesn't notice it distracted by the fact
that he doesn't remember getting bullied
in the next scene shaushi and hwang ki
are out on a dinner date xiaoshi asks
him if he would like her the same if she
were to gain weight wanky replies that
they should talk about positive things
like her upcoming acting career it is
clear to her that he won't think twice
before leaving her if he sees her real
self after dinner she goes to the old
mansion yet again and asks the miracle
man for a permanent potion he gives her
the potion but warns her that it will
cause a side effect on her life that she
might not like blinded by her need to be
huanky's girlfriend xiaoshi takes the
potion at the same time hans starts to
lose his memories of her he only
remembers that she was someone he used
to know in his childhood the next day is
the release day of the music video
cheshie walks into a hall for a press
conference when she notices the crew
looking at her differently she tries
talking to hwang he but he ignores her
when they are surrounded by the
reporters she finds out that the rumor
of her getting liposuction has
circulated on the internet since being
seen with her is not a good pr move for
huanki he announces that he is in a
relationship with someone else some fans
in the crowd throw their drinks at
xiaoshi for lying about her beauty han
saves her from the media and brings her
upstairs xiao xi soon realizes that he
only remembers the overweight xiaoshi
and thinks that he hasn't met her for a
while she tries to show him their
pictures together but her face is
missing in all of them she breaks down
crying but han just thinks she's in
shock from what happened earlier a week
later huanki comes to her house she
welcomes him in expecting him to
apologize but he asks her to convince
han to sell him a song on finding out he
just wants to use her for her influence
she asks him to get out following the
encounter shaoxi rushes to his office
and finds a picture of them from high
school she finally realizes that she
never stopped loving han and has been
suppressing her feelings until now after
that she goes to the abandoned house
once again this time to ask the man to
send her back to her normal self the man
gives her one last chance and allows her
to transform after turning fat again
shaoxi runs to the playground and meets
han when he calls her by her name she
breaks down crying relieved that he
remembers her one year later the couple
is at their favorite street side
restaurant by now shaoshi has become fit
while han has gained a significant
amount of weight the movie ends as she
tells him that she loves him either way
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching